all this happened so eager so eager to
get back in it
going knight f3 before i can even sit
down
okay that's noted that is noted
oh it's just on the
anti-grunfeld thing that he
that he was doing against um against
zwiddler
okay so enough h6 then this time i'm
gonna go
a6 instead let's see what he's got in
star
uh yeah so h3
is what i did
when i did myself
uh against fabian and also i think
what i niche played against me
so so far
standard stuff
okay queen c2 then i guess i'll go g6
or do i wait i guess i'll go to g6
rook f1
very interesting stuff
so maybe his plan is to
because one one plan for black here is
to go
queen e7 at some point and then reroute
the knights
from ea to the d6 so maybe his point is
sort of to preempt that by
hitting at e4 once i start doing those
things
okay i guess i'll go a5 for now
always seems to be fairly useful
okay we'll go rook f8
just wait a bit try and keep him
guessing
i feel like i might go b5 at some point
just a little bit a little bit difficult
to come up with
with useful moves here has to be said
yeah not a four
once that comes i think i should jump in
if it takes twice there's bishop e3
so it takes once because knight d2
i don't love it because it's weakening
my king but i think i should go f5
and it is
sort of a caricon french structure with
colors reversed which
sort of suggests that um
it's something where like if you were
playing black you would be pretty happy
but
with uh with the white pieces it feels
like it's probably
a bit too soft and or um
um for getting a um serious advantage
maybe i if i'd gone a four there
he had some initiative with knight c4
all of the rook endings are a bit worse
but i think here just going b6 and then
c5 i
i'm completely fine
so wherever he moves his rook now i'm
gonna go c5
okay and of course there's no
pen with rook e to c1 because i have two
two pieces covering c8
and if he takes roxy one obviously i go
rook to b8
and i attack b2 and if he takes and see
if
c5 rook rick takes b2 i have no problems
whatsoever
he probably will go rook c2 then but
then i
bring the the king into the game and i
have
i have absolutely no worries if his
knight was a little bit more active here
i might have been a bit worse but now i
think it's just fine
it was maybe also d8 there which could
be considered
okay so i don't have the plan of going
bishop no there's
bishop is not going to to be one that's
protected by the knights
yes i think if the game proceeds more or
less normally here we should head
towards
a draw but anything can can happen still
of course
i was thinking a lot here because
i'd feel as though he doesn't really
doesn't really find the whole position
very very promising
i don't even know need to go to c6
though
so his plan is find his king c1 and the
knight c4 maybe
so i'll go to c6 after all and now i'll
push a4
a4 might be a slight weakness
um once he puts the knight in c3 but
also my
my bishop is landing on on b3 so i don't
think it's uh
it's a real worry
okay
i think i'll take this opportunity to
try and improve making side of it
yeah so bishop e3 and now h5 and i want
to go h4
to get a bit of a clamp here and
he is very solid of course um
but i do think he's a little bit worse
now i go g4 i believe
or is g for any good
no i think g4 is good because he has
such problems with this king here
yeah so this was this was my point
that he can hardly hardly take
because taking a fight because rook g2
comes and
he has um
he i don't think he can both stop
um stop all of my my uh
mating ideas and h3 ideas and
yeah i guess here here he sort of
sort of survives but i'm i'm still
considerably better
okay maybe i'm i'm not
a lot better actually
it's kind of uh improving his pieces and
making it difficult for me to progress
i really need to push that guy to
to h4 now sorry to h3
we know e4 is not a not a bad idea but i
can't go h3 so
it's it's not looking that great
now e4 i think okay now we go h3
or h4 k5
okay this is gonna come down to speed a
bit as well
oh i keep on blundering a4 what am i
doing
okay i think we'll take okay it doesn't
allow bishop
okay this is this is just a mess
it's just a total and other mass now
he'll take an a4 i think
okay let's go to kf4 first
okay now now he's just losing
h2 coming king e3 rook d3 is mates
okay yeah that was
that was a horrendous mess what happened
like my pawn on a4 was hanging all the
time
and neither of us could keep our heads
cool
just a mess